- I only eat non-flavored lube.
I refuse to eat the, that's a joke.
It's not funny.
- Oh, I was like, wait,
you really do eat it?
(upbeat music)
- Whiskey Dick.
(laughing)
- In my experience isn't a good thing.
- I think they're trying to take it back.
- Taking it back.
- Like, it's our thing now.
- It smells like whiskey.
- It smells like a failed
night with a whiskey dick.
- Ew!
- It actually does taste
like whiskey, though.
I'm surprised.
- You know, it's kinda good.
- It tastes like
something you'd give a cat
that has a fungal infection.
- I wouldn't do this.
- I would do this, after...
- Right.
- That'd get me in the
mood more than this would.
- Whiskey Dick, not too bad.
- Yeah. In this form, obviously.
- Red Velvet Cake.
- Cake, cake, cake,
cake, cake, cake, cake.
- This is the nicest bottle.
- I'm singing Rihanna right now.
- Oh, sorry, carry on.
- It either looks like a
hand soap or an elixir.
- This smells like...
- I'm not getting a good
vibe on the smell right now.
- Yeah, it almost smells like a perm.
- Doesn't smell like red velvet at all.
- I think I get little hints.
- It smells like clown urine.
- Clown urine!
- How do you know what
clown urine smells like?
- What?
- Oh.
- Wait, what the [beep]?
- It also has the very
sharp like "don't eat this!"
- Yeah.
- Feeling about it.
- The cake looks good, but...
- This cake looks great.
- And the bottle is
great, the tagline great.
The taste? Ugh.
- We got some Bacon Lube!
They make everything with bacon.
- Bacon doesn't make me think of sex.
It makes me think of like...
- It makes me think of sex.
- Church.
- Bottoms up.
- Oh, God, that is...
- It tastes terrible.
- That is horrendous.
- Can I have this bacon?
- No, wait, yeah, I need
that to wash it down.
- There's no bacon flavor to that at all.
- There's no. No.
- It's the one thing to
ruin bacon for the world.
- Garbage.
- Get rid of it.
- Bye.
- [Blonde Woman] Squirting Cum Lube? Ew!
- So, natural flavors.
- What if this is just bottled cum?
- Do it blind without looking?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I'm totally down.
(woman shrieking)
- Oh.
- That doesn't taste like jizz.
- Tastes like cough syrup.
- It doesn't taste anything like cum
or something you should eat.
- I need a water.
- Squirting Cum Lube.
- Ew, oh my God.
(man yells)
That's [beep] disgusting.
Why would anyone want that?
- As someone who started
this not using lube,
I don't think that this taste test
has really convinced me.
- I don't know if I
need it to be flavored.
- When it comes to lube and
sexual stuff, you do you.